meine damen und herren ich danke ihnen
dass sie heute mittag so kurzfristig
zeit gefunden haben hierher zu kommen
ich habe mich zu diesem kurzen
pressetermin entschlossen weil ich heute
vormittag entschieden habe die
notwendigen verordnungen für die am
montag vereinbarte zusätzliche oster
ruhe also die ruhetage am gründonnerstag
und karsamstag nicht auf den weg zu
bringen sondern sie zu stoppen und das
klipp und klar zu sagen die idee eines
oster shutdown zwar mit bester absicht
entworfen worden
denn wir müssen es unbedingt schaffen
die dritte welle der pandemie zu bremsen
und umzukehren
dennoch war die idee der sogenannten
oster ruhe ein fehler
sie hatte ihre guten gründe war aber in
der kürze der zeit nicht gut genug
umsetzbar wenn sie überhaupt jemals so
umsetzbar ist dass aufwand und nutzen in
einem halbwegs vernünftigen verhältnis
stehen
viel zu viele fragen von der
lohnfortzahlung durch die ausgefallenen
arbeitsstunden bis zu der lage in den
geschäften und betrieben können das
haben die beratungen der letzten 24
stunden gezeigt jedenfalls in der kürze
der zeit nicht so gelöst werden wie es
nötig wäre und ob auch ein zweites klipp
und klar zu sagen
dieser fehler ist einzig und allein mein
fehler
denn am ende trage ich für alles die
letzte verantwortung qua amt ist das so
also auch für die am montag getroffene
entscheidung zur sogenannten oster das
habe ich die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten wollen auch in einer
kurzen video konferenz erläutert und
darüber auch die vorsitzenden der
fraktionen im deutschen bundestag
informiert und es ist mir wichtig dass
auch hier zu sagen ein fehler muss als
fehler benannt werden und vor allem muss
er korrigiert werden und ermöglicht hat
dass noch rechtzeitig zu geschehen
gleichwohl weiß ich natürlich dass
dieser gesamte vorgang zusätzliche
verunsicherung auslöst
das bedauere ich zutiefst und dafür
bitte ich alle bürgerinnen und bürger um
verzeihung
diese zusätzliche verunsicherung
bedauerlich umso mehr als wir uns dabei
bleibt es leider mitten in der durch die
mutation ausgelösten dritten welle der
pandemie befinden ich danke einmal mehr
allen die mit ihrem verhalten dazu
beitragen die dritte welle mit der
tödlichen und ansteckenden mutation des
corona virus zu bremsen und zu stoppen
dazu bietet der beschluss vom montag
auch ohne die sogenannte oster ruhe
einen rahmen mit der notbremse mit der
möglichkeit von regional zu
entscheidenden ausgangs begrenzungen und
kontakt beschränkungen mit dem ausbau
des testens natürlich auch mit der immer
weiter verstärkenden impfkampagne am 12
april werden die wir die beratungen
fortsetzen und ich bin zutiefst davon
überzeugt wir werden das virus gemeinsam
besiegen
der weg ist hart und er ist steinig er
ist auch von erfolgen aber auch von
fehlern und rückschlägen gekennzeichnet
aber das virus wird langsam aber sicher
seinen schrecken verlieren
und bis dahin setzen wir mit allen
maßnahmen weiter alles daran dass unser
gesundheitssystem der immensen belastung
standhält und zugleich diese überaus
großen folgen für wirtschaft bildung
kultur und für unser ganzes
zusammenleben aufgefangen werden ich
bitte sie um verständnis dass ich jetzt
keine fragen beantworten weil ich gleich
um 13 uhr den abgeordneten im deutschen
bundestag rede und antwort stehen
herzlichen dank